Si algo ha dejado claro el conflicto de Ucrania,
es que nadie es más creativo y eficaz anexionándose
o liberando territorios al margen del derecho
internacional que Rusia.
Su presidente, Vladimir Putin, está convencido
de la grandeza de su nación, y ha dejado
caer en varias ocasiones que la desmembración
de la Unión Soviética fue, a su manera de
ver, la mayor catástrofe geopolítica del
siglo XX.
Así, no es de extrañar que desde el Kremlin
se las estén ideando para recuperar el poderío
geopolítico que consideran que les corresponde
históricamente.
Rusia considera que los países de la antigua
URSS deben de permanecer bajo su influencia,
y que en consecuencia otros países no deberían
incurrir en sus asuntos, ya que sería meter
las narices en los asuntos
de Rusia.
Pero ya no contentos con la existencia de
las antiguas repúblicas soviéticas demasiado
independientes para su gusto, Rusia lleva
ya unos años apoyando a las regiones más
prorrusas de todos estos países en sus procesos
de independencia.
Ya os hablamos de cómo está gestionando
Rusia la crisis en el Este de Ucrania, reconociendo
unilateralmente y de facto la independencia
de Donetsk y Luhansk, sin considerarlas, de
momento, parte de
su propio territorio.
Pero no es la primera vez que lo hacen: antes
vinieron Crimea, Abjasia, Osetia del Sur y
la más desconocida pero que está volviendo
a ganar importancia en el nuevo contexto de
movida en ucrania/tira y afloja con la OTAN:
Transnistria.
Tema de hoy.
Transnistria es uno de los lugares más extraños
que existen, pasear por las calles de Tiráspol,
su capital, supone retroceder 40 años en
el tiempo, regresar a la época de la Unión
Soviética o sentirse en una especie de Corea
del Norte Occidental.
Transnistria está situada en Europa del
Este, dentro del territorio que anteriormente
formaba la República Socialista Soviética
de Moldavia, que era parte de la Unión Soviética.
Pues bien, la situación hoy de este territorio
en la comunidad internacional es bastante
peculiar, Transnistria es un estado no reconocido,
es decir un país en la práctica independiente
pero que formalmente continua perteneciendo
a Moldavia.
LA DIVISIÓN DE MOLDAVIA
De la misma manera que el río Dniéper divide
a Ucrania en dos regiones separadas ideológicamente,
el Dniéster divide desde 1990 a Moldavia
entre, literalmente, el estado de Moldavia
y la República Moldava Pridnestroviana o
Transnistria.
Las diferencias entre los habitantes de ambas
regiones son principalmente étnicas y lingüísticas.
Mientras que, en Moldavia, ESTÁ formada por
ciudadanos de etnia moldava rumanoparlantes,
en Transnistria domina una clara mayoría
eslava que habla ruso o ucraniano como lengua
principal.
Fue de hecho el miedo a la rumanización del
país tras su independencia lo que sumió
a los rusófonos del Este en una crisis de
identidad, ya que tras la caída de la URSS
perdieron el dominio cultural que hasta entonces
tenían en el país.
En este contexto, automáticamente tras la
restauración de la independencia de Moldavia
en 1990, Transnistria quiso unirse a la ola
de democratización que en aquel entonces
liberaba a las catorce repúblicas soviéticas,
algo que no se vio con buenos ojos desde Chisinau.
Las tensiones entre la capital moldava y Tiraspol
fueron escalando hasta causar una auténtica
guerra civil que duró de marzo a julio del
92.
Pero no sólo hubo moldavos y transnistrios
enfrentados en este conflicto.
En efecto, Rusia se posicionó de parte de
Transnistria y se pasó por ahí para encargarse
de garantizar su independencia.
La guerra terminó con un alto al fuego que
se lleva respetando desde entonces.
Pero este alto al fuego no sólo ponía fin
a las hostilidades, sino que oficializaba
la entrada de tropas rusas al este del Dniéster,
que más de 20 años después siguen ahí
con el pretexto de apoyar al gobierno transnistrio.
A día de hoy en Transnistria están desplegados
2.500 soldados rusos, así como más de 20.000
toneladas de armas y municiones propiedad
de Rusia.
Según un veredicto emitido por el Tribunal
Europeo de Derechos Humanos, la presencia
de estas tropas es ilegal y supone que este
territorio está bajo la autoridad efectiva
o por lo menos bajo la influencia decisiva
de Rusia.
Obviamente para los moldavos esto en su día
supuso un acto hostil que violaba su integridad
territorial, y la verdad es que el derecho
internacional les ampara porque desde Chisinau
no se ha autorizado la intervención.
Pero ellos tampoco tienen el poder para echar
a Rusia ya que el alto al fuego les impide
hacer nada que comprometa la independencia
de facto de Transnistria.
LA PARTICULAR IDENTIDAD DE TRANSNISTRIA
Aunque sólo haya sido reconocido hasta ahora
por otras tres regiones como estado independiente
(S. Osetia, Abjasia, Nagorno-Karabaj), lo
cierto es que Transnistria actualmente funciona
como un verdadero estado independiente: tiene
su propia moneda, el rublo transnistrio; su
propio himno nacional, su propio pasaporte
al que sus ciudadanos tienen derecho sin rechazar
al Moldavo, un banco republicano transnistrio
independiente del moldavo…
Y, a pesar de que no les han reconocido como
estado independiente, el amor de la región
por Rusia es más que obvia.
De hecho, este mismo mes se ha llevado a la
corte suprema transnistria por la que la bandera
rusa tendría el mismo estatus que la bandera
nacional.
Esto es, que la bandera blanca, azul y roja
se pondría en todos los edificios públicos
y sería, a ojos de los transnistrios, su
propia bandera.
La predilección de los transnistrios con
Rusia llega a tal punto que en 2013 el Consejo
Supremo de Transnistria aprobó el uso de
la legislación rusa en todo el territorio
de esta autoproclamada república.
Actualmente se están eliminando todas las
disposiciones legales que sean contradictorias
con la legislación rusa.
El objetivo último de las autoridades de
este territorio es claro: incorporar la república
a la Federación rusa.
Sin embargo, para poder lograrlo Moscú tiene
que reconocer primero su independencia.
Ahora bien, viendo este amor tan incondicional,
¿por qué no reconoce Rusia a Transnistria
como estado independiente?
La respuesta es que al Kremlin le interesa
que en cierta manera Transnistria siga perteneciendo
de alguna manera a Moldavia, para poder usarla
como baza en su estrategia geopolítica.
Así, Moscú puede evitar fácilmente que
Moldavia tome cualquier decisión que le aleje
de su radio de influencia.
¿Se os ocurre qué quiere evitar el Kremlin
principalmente?
En efecto, Rusia se encarga de esta manera
de que Moldavia no tenga la feliz idea de
subirse al carro de la OTAN o de acercarse
más de la cuenta a la UE, cosa que ya hicieron
sus vecinos Rumanía y Ucrania, con las consecuencias
para la segunda que ya todos conocemos.
Aunque de momento no parece que haya ninguna
intención por parte de Moldavia de unirse
a ninguna organización internacional occidental,
especialmente desde los resultados de sus
elecciones en octubre, en las que salió victorioso
el prorruso Igor Dodon, que ha prometido alejarse
de Europa y reforzar los lazos de Chisinau
con Moscú.
El socialista prorruso Igor Dodon se convirtió
en el nuevo presidente de Moldavia tras obtener
en las elecciones presidenciales de 2016 casi
el 52% de los votos.
Dodon es un ferviente admirador del presidente
ruso Vladimir Putin.
Su intención como presidente pasa por frenar
la integración con la Unión Europea y firmar
un Acuerdo de Asociación Estratégica con
Rusia.
Un Nuevo Kaliningrado
Pero no nos olvidemos de que a todo esto sigue
habiendo tropas rusas en un territorio extranjero,
algo que en Bruselas no sienta del todo bien.
Porque recordemos que, además de permitirle
controlar a Moldavia, la situación política
y geográfica de Transnistria también da
la posibilidad a Rusia de controlar militarmente
un territorio que ahora mismo resulta clave:
En primer lugar, hacia el este, Transnistria
tiene frontera con Ucrania, ahora mismo sumida
en una guerra contra Rusia por las regiones
del Donbas.
Por lo que seguir a orillas del Dniéper les
da la posibilidad de cercar a Ucrania desde
dos flancos distintos, ejerciendo una presión
que baila entre la diplomacia dura y la blanda
para recordarles que el oso ruso está ahí,
velando por su territorio.
Y por otra parte, hacia el oeste, la manutención
ccanía, algo que en Moscú se ha visto como
una acción agresiva por parte de la organización.
En definitiva, Rusia ha encontrado en Transnistria
su segundo Kaliningrado, que en estos momentos
le resulta más útil que nunca.